So now that the functionality of this webLet
me rephrase it so now that the functionality
of our.
Little clicker game is made and set up
We know we have the foundation of our
website reallyIn great condition.
And this is always the most important part
of a websiteCuz sometimes.
People will actually have a habit which can
kind of be a bad habit to overstow so pretty
much make the style of the
website what it look like on when I was
showing it off without actually making any
functionality so they'll have the buttons
where
they need to go they'll have the dudes
looking really cool but they'll spend way
too much time and focus on maybe the
way it looks but in reality when it's
someone starts to try when someone starts to
interact with those objects they do nothing
It can be kind of disappointing toLet me
rephrase that.
It can be a very disappointing experience
for a user if they're on your website and
they're excited to play the
game that you have built out for him and
nothing works and they're just clicking buns
that actually don't do anythingSo.
It's always really important to remember
functionality before form is like to say get
all the functionality
working and then let's actually design this
website to look the way we wanted to look
So let's go ahead and head back to vs code
And let's start actually working on those
stylesFrom here I'm actually going to import
some assets.
And then we got our attack button in here we
got some other buttons in here as well or
some other images rather
So let's go to our index.html we'll close
this out
And now let's get into just dialing out this
page the way we want
So we'll go back since now we're actually
going to style it the way the finished
product look we'll convert this back to a
container fluid
cuz we want this to look like the entire
Battlefield we want the whole viewport to be
that battlefield of those two fighting each
other
We'll get rid of this padding as well since
we won't have the buttonsThe way that they
were designed.
And we're actually going to do a two call
fives here
Cuz if you remember from the reference it
was built out we kind of want those two
individual buttons in the middle
So having two call fives on both sides
allows us to actually put our buns in
between these
We can actually put our buttons hereAnd a
call to within the same row.
So let's just go ahead and move
These buns up into there so we'll just
actually move the individual ones
And after we move these up here we will also
make sure to get rid of
Those days down here so let's go ahead and
clean this up as well let's make sure we get
the entire rowGet him out of there. Sweet.
So at this point let's go to our web appWe
can see we get those two buttons in the
middle awesome.
So we'll wrap this attack in a PTACWe'll say
attack.
Let's actually we'll do text uppercase on
this P tag as well
And let's also addSome red to it so we'll do
danger text.
And this will be a custom CSS class will
make in our own CSS and let's actually open
this up as well
And we'll do the same thing for this
potionSo let's actually put a P tag in here
and we'll call this one potion.
And we'll actually call this success text
And we're going to add some of our own
custom CSS to this as wellAnd let's do.
To uppercase as well so we'll do text
uppercaseSweet.
So let's go back up to our row and we'll add
some more classes to our row
Let's just fire content betweenAnd let's
align our items to the center.
The next class I want to add in is going to
be called the battlefield
This is going to be that background image we
had when we looked on it our previous or a
reference project
But if we save for now and let's go back
We actually see some getting some centerness
centerness and we canGet our buttons in
here.
But let's not go to our styles.css we'll get
rid of this hello world and
we'll actually create that Battlefield class
and we'll create that text success as
wellSo.
Let's access that and we'll go to the
battlefieldAnd I want to set this to a
dynamic view height.
Of that 100 viewportI'm going to access a
background image.
And it's very important once again to make
sure we target that URL
And then make sure we put those quotes
around
And Lincoln that are tag or our and make
sure we Link in the address of that image
SweetSo if we were just to save this we
should get a background image but it's
probably not going to look that good.
So now we get the tach potion and then we
can kind of see the text but it's a little
dark but we get
that background but it's just going to keep
repeating over itself as well just because
it's native sizes and the size of this
viewport
So let's go back to our CSS and we can
change that background sizeBy accessing the
background size.
We'll just have cover for thatAnd then we'll
also Target the background position.
And we're going to just make sure it's
centered on the screen
So now we get that big background to set up
our battlefield for our hero and the coding
virus
While we're here I'm going to set up a new
section I'm going to call this section my
text section
Let's actually make those two texts that we
set up earlier so we'll do a danger text
this is going to be very similar to just
text danger but I'm going to addI'm going to
add a little bit of font weight to it.
WhoopsSo let's target font weight.
Let's give it a heftiness so we'll give it
800 which is going to make it quite a bit
more bold
And then we'll also add some text Shadow to
it
I'm going to add some white text Shadow so
let's say this and look at it
So awesome we get thatNice effect with the
white.
So it's add the same to our potion
So for this one I'm going to do pretty much
the same except instead of red we're going
to use the success of green
It's like I said will do essentially the
same thing we'll use Font weight 800
And then we'll actually just go ahead and
copy this text shadow inSave that. And let's
take a look at it.
Sweet so we got our two button set upLet's
continue back in our HTML.
So now that we're into section Hero Let's go
ahead and label this sectionIt's actually go
ahead and label all these sections.
Let me look up a semantics thing
I'm pretty sure they can call looms I
misspelled columns are concessions be
columns
HTML
So remember we were reading something about
you should use sections over divs
I feel like this would be a good use case
for that
Whatever I'm not to worry about it doesn't
really it was more of a semantic thing
So let's target this call five and all this
call five I'm going to make the text Center
And I'm going to set another unique class
cuz I need to set the height of this parent
call five here
And we'll go to our Styles at CSSSo I have
my text we won't create this in my text.
Can I just want the height of this divThis
parent did to be 75% and I'll show off what
that's going to do.
Just make sure everything's saved
You see immediately we get our heroes Health
at the top and let's actually inspect this
to see the difference of what's going on in
between these two
Cuz right now we can see this is that parent
row
And if you notice we get a lot more height
and coverage of the entire viewport then if
I go to this villains
If I click on the actual row you can see the
row is only going to be the height of the
children within it
that row but if we were to do the same thing
for this villain height and set it to a
static height of 75%
We can actually get this to grow to the size
that we want in spite of the contents within
the container itself
But from here we'll continue with the hero
section we'll add aJustify content Center to
this.
Rose well cuz we're going to want the hero
and all the health within here to be
centered on the screen
So within here so within here
So within this row we'll actually go ahead
and change it to a call 10 so it won't be so
wide
Instead of having toInstead of having to
Hero's Health let's actually make this the
code Works Crusaders.
And since we capitalize everything I'll just
make this age capitalize
And let's actually set this font size so
let's give this a font size of three
And what's create another class called the
header text which will use for this and the
villain as well
So let's go create that within our text
section
So we'll do that by just opening up that
header text and actually scroll down here
I'm going to set the color of that text to
White
And we'll apply text Shadow to it as well
just to allowed to pop out a little bit more
And we'll give it a blackShadow. And let's
add a little bit of a border here.
And we're actually going to make this border
dotted so let's save thatAnd go take a look
at what that looks like.
Awesome so now we applied that font size 3
So we set the phone a lot higher we also
made the font white and we create that kind
of that black
Text Shadow on as well and a white dotted
border
And I'll show off the text Shadow itself so
we can seeThe.
Code Works Health right there so it's
actually go to this header text
And we'll actually open this up a little bit
moreLet's go to our elements or.
So let's take a look at what that text
shadow
So that's the difference of having text
Shadow and not like I said it just makes it
look a lot softer
and not so sharp or have that glow and it
just looks better as well depending on the
background was white
That's why I like to add a text Shadow to
just open text on that's kind of floating
around
And if you know the background might not be
black
So from here we'll continue downTo our
actual hero.
So make sure to go down underneath this row
We're going to add an image tagAnd this
source is going to be from the images I
added earlier.
And it's going to be this pixel hero.png
And then I'm going to sign a alt tag of here
that's the code Works crusaderImage.
And I also want to send an ID
So I can access this from my JavaScript if I
want to add any
if I want to add any JavaScript or custom
CSS from later on
Let's go ahead and also add a title to this
will add the title of what I should say the
code Works crusader
And also add a class to this as well and
this is going to take on the
Same class from earlier we're actually just
going to reuse that Crusader height is 75%
So let's take a quick look at what this
looks like